breaking moments ago US forces just
launched multiple targeted airstrikes
against iranian-backed militias this in
a direct response to the rocket attack
that killed two American troops at a
base in Iraq much more on this coming up
tonight but first at this hour the
impact of coronavirus
is being felt all across the United
States we have cancellations and school
closures tourneys canceled and
professional athletic events canceled
now for some might seem like this is the
world coming to an end now we'll start
with facts not fear make no mistake the
corona virus every virus has we have
been telling you you must take it
seriously it has been and it is being
taken seriously as a nation we must take
every and all necessary precautions but
we also we need to become we need to be
strategic we need to be smart we need to
have the right perspective any death is
a tragedy
I would like cures for cancer I've said
this before many times heart disease
every disease we lose in this country
tens of thousands of Americans every
single year from the flu I hope we find
a cure for that the common cold that'd
be great this is a health challenge we
need to rise to the occasion as we
always do we are the United States of
America you know the words the land of
the free and the home of the brave
they're not just words and an anthem
those are words that accurately define
us as a people this is the country that
beat back the forces of Nazism and
communism and fascism in Imperial Japan
this is the country that has the single
best doctors and scientists and medical
researchers on the face of the earth
this is the country that has accumulated
more power and advanced the human
condition more than any other economic
system anywhere in the world or the
history of man so tonight like every
night in this program we will bring you
facts without fear without the politics
of panic running rampant in the country
we're going to give you perspective and
context and data and information
information that you can use to protect
yourself your family your loved ones
most of you which sadly you will not get
from the deranged agenda driven media
mob let's start just 24 hours ago
president
Trump he was delivering a very serious
address to the nation from The Oval
Office during that speech he outlined
new measures including restrictions now
on European travel on top of the Bands
already in place you also offered
financial relief for those impacted
industry and workers as well the
president also called for unity said
quote we are all in this together we
must put politics aside stop the
partisanship unify together as one
nation one family
needless to say didn't take needles to
say it didn't take long the rage the
hate the conspiracy theorists on the
Left they are not heeding that advice
sadly and from them everything and I
mean everything is seen through a 20/20
election prism now since the very
beginning all they have done is use this
fire as politicized this virus to
bludgeon President Trump all the same
people that have done the same thing for
three straight years
it is sad it is not surprising they have
been doing this Russia Russia Ukraine
Ukraine and peach and peach Corona now
Corona
they didn't unify even around the
destruction of the Isis caliphate
how great is that or killing of al
Baghdadi and associates or killing
Soleimani or the al Qaeda leader in
Yemen now the verdict is in and
immediately they refused to even rally
around an important fight against what
is a deadly virus and disease Maxine
Waters calling the president a liar who
needs to shut his mouth about
coronavirus yes the compromise the
corrupt Adam Schiff calling the
administration incompetent quote
incompetence kills over there at fake
news CNN he have fake news Jimmy Acosta
well he's most worried about the
president's terminology thinking the
President's speech was racist because he
said the virus started in China
here's his own words at one point during
this address the president referred to
the corona virus as a quote foreign
virus that that I think was interesting
because as I was talking to sources
earlier this evening one of the points
that the president wanted to make
tonight wanted to get across to
Americans is that this virus did not
start here but that they're dealing with
it and I think it's going to spec it's
going to come across to a lot of
Americans as smacking of xenophobia to
use that kind of term in this speech
Chris
as it turns out fake news Acosta's also
referred to Coronas foreign roots on his
own Twitter himself in January yep fake
news Acosta called at Wuhan coronavirus
I guess by his own definition fake news
Acosta's a xenophobe as you can see very
same people that were involved in
everything for the last three years
every conspiracy theory scam 24/7 every
second minute hour of every day they are
back and guess what they're not about to
let a crisis go to waste
irrational hatred towards the president
is now putting Americans in danger this
is the message we need to understand
tonight
the president is trying to protect the
country instead of working together to
help the American people
you have the mob and of course the
radical Democratic Socialist Party
they're working hand in hand to just
smear the president they have not said
one good thing about what he has done
not one he didn't do anything right this
goes against everything our founders put
into place watch this the president last
night he kind of wished at his chance to
convince Americans that he has a plan
for dealing with the spread of the virus
here domestically and he just set the
stage for Joe Biden to kind of walk on
in and look presidential
we have far as he misspoke about Europe
he misspoke about the the intensity of
this ban and that's on him the errors he
has made for several weeks now were on
him this country is behind for several
weeks it's on him China we know it's not
your bad but could you please send Brian
Kilmeade an edible arrangement so he'll
shut cop tying coronavirus to China and
Chinese people isn't just a racist dog
whistle it's a whole racist Orchestra
all right here's a question what what
are these hate Trump acts what would
they like the president to do because I
challenge anyone in the media mob fake
news CNN the New York Times which
selectively edits and lies every day or
in the Democratic Party what are your
ideas bring them forward to the American
people put them on the table and we'll
work together and solve this pandemic
the
Ruth is no president has done this much
or acted this quickly then Donald Trump
no president in history here are the
facts over fear on December 30th an
unknown disease was first observed in
Wuhan China that's the truth
January 7th they said at the time it
would add pneumonia like symptoms but
they didn't identify it as coronavirus
until January 7th important date by
January 31st the Trump administration
declared a public health emergency
Americans abroad were then subject to
mandatory quarantine zhan military bases
hadn't been done in decades
February 2nd President ordered a
temporary travel ban for all non US
citizens who recently visited China at
the very same time now what were the
Democrats doing what were people in the
mob and the media doing what were they
doing to help combat the virus you might
ask well the answer is nothing most of
them were completely totally infatuated
with one issue impeaching Donald Trump
like usual meanwhile other members of
the Democratic Party and Congress
actually suggesting the president's
travel ban was racist
now that w-h-o chief well he said that
restrictions were needed to stop the
outbreak and that they would only
increase fear in stigma the government
of China agreed accusing Trump of
overreacting to the virus and of course
democratic party's frontrunner quid pro
quo Joe On January 31st when the
president put his travel ban in effect
he said it was xenophobic and hysterical
take a look and I was like this this is
where credibly a president is most
needed as he explains what we should and
should not do this is no time for Donald
Trump's record of hysteria xenophobia
hysterical xenophobia - and
fear-mongering to lead the way instead
of science stereo okay on this program
doctor foul she said that the
president's travel ban against China
likely prevented an untold amount of
exposure and suffering in place now by
the way neither Biden or his comrade
Bernie Sanders supported the ban neither
one of them
would have enacted it this one
courageous early act that Donald Trump
took a lot of heat for did more to
protect the spread of this disease that
one decision January 31st three weeks in
while they were impeaching the president
I'd say doing a thing on corona that one
decision
did more than any other thing that could
have been done and all the president got
was called names in fact let's look at
some perspective here back in 2009 we
have a Biden Obama record on a global
pandemic
this is h1n1 and the well I'll use Joe's
words the Abidin bomber ticket as he
calls it well they never enacted a
travel ban that year the CDC estimated
get this in the year that we had the
first year that virus sixty point eight
million Americans were infected with
h1n1 no travel ban in other words one in
five Americans got that disease in the
first year that resulted in over two
hundred and seventy four thousand
Americans hospitalized nearly 13,000
deaths in that year alone worldwide up
to five hundred and seventy five
thousand people died in two thousand
nine and ten that first year April to
April from h1n1 better known as a swine
flu no travel ban no state of emergency
wasn't a declared until what October
they knew about it in April one health
administrator did say was an emergency
eleven days in but not the president not
Obama he did that in October of that
year after a thousand Americans had died
and tens of thousands of Americans had
contracted that disease that virus and
naturally despite thousands of deaths
millions of cases the media mobs
coverage at the time Wow
very different it was measured it was
calm the mob supported their president
they loved their president take a look
let's talk about this is something that
is concerning a whole lot of people
these days we're talking about the h1n1
and now the President President Barack
Obama declaring the swine flu outbreak a
national emergency should
there be a worst-case scenario but
administration officials are emphasizing
here fredericka it's not that they are
expecting one more than a thousand
people in the US have died from the h1n1
virus 90 in the last week the federal
government had predicted there would be
a hundred million doses of vaccine by
now but as of this weekend about 11
million were available when we hear
emergency alarm bells start to go off
what exactly does this declaration mean
well the first thing to say is people
shouldn't panic when they hear this
health officials battling the h1n1 flu
virus this weekend have received two
booster shots of their own President
Obama has declared the virus of national
emergency that was six months in a
thousand Americans were dead tens of
thousands contracted that disease
compare that to the nine alarm
anti-trump hysteria on right now all day
every day at pretty much every news
network look I understand pandemics
scary
nobody likes pandemics no one wants
anybody to get sick people are scared I
have no problem with cancellations no
problem taking every precaution
necessary I understand the criticism the
testing kids took too long to come out
fair criticism that's been rectified now
they're becoming readily available the
case numbers will surely rise definitely
in the short-term we believe it will
level off we hope so if everyone does
their part hopefully we will be able to
get to the other side of all of this
make no mistake all virus is a dangerous
serious stuff make sure to keep an eye
out for your older loved ones your
grandparents your parents those that
perhaps have underlying medical
conditions immune compromised of some
kind COPD lung disease but in this
country we don't were not a country that
lives in fear we're the country that
tackles problems head-on the facts of
the facts three weeks in this president
acted he acted faster and quicker and
did more to stop the spread of that
disease than any other time in American
history travel bans billions in support
financial support all hands on deck
from the get-go from the administration
or the Democrats doing they were
impeaching ultimately there's no doubt
we will overcome this disease this virus
America will come roaring back that's a
fact
at some point China they're going to be
forced to answer for the spread of this
deadly disease and the lies that they
told